you've got you've got details there the
slides will be up on SlideShare and
speaker deck afterwards so that's enough
about me and my personal life Python is
apt hyphen is absolutely rubbish at
speed so that's that's not very good but
i will add at computation because if
you're doing io stuff you don't care
because you're just sitting there
waiting and that's fine pythons very
good at waiting however I as Ian's
pointed out I'm a believer that
computers are there to serve actually
they're there to contribute to the
heating of the planet which is the anti
green tea anyway more to point is this
is a CPU bound i/o bound thing and I'm
not going to get into Python as IO flask
and all that sort of stuff great love it
anything with an event loop you're
probably not going to even warm up the
CPU we're actually talking about real
crunching stuff here and when it comes
down to it a Python he is a mess when it
comes to doing numbers so you want to
actually get rid of that and so rather
than just waffle in the abstract which
is a waste of time and effort really we
sent we sent the Python off to do some
research into a really interesting
problem that would fit on one slide and
yet have everything we need to know
about parallelism and so he came back
with pine which seems fairly reasonable
and no I don't mean what I mean is what
is the value of pi and interestingly of
course we know exactly what the value of
pi is okay it'll take a while I think
along but never mind
have you noticed how meerkats really
know about pie
now oh never mind we haven't got any
mathematicians in the room so what we're
going to be doing is approximating the
value of pi so that we've got some
number and I don't mean just going mad
pie yeah the problem with math pies it
can change you've tried that one math
dot pi equals 3.2 pythons happy with
that and it's great for the lawmakers in
Illinois who in the 1890s tried to pass
a law to say that pie was 3.2
fortunately the newspapers stepped in
stop that happening so people had a
chance to have a look at that equation
you're no way you're going to do with
that numerically integral equations we
need to make an approximation to pie and
so we go to some form of summation and
hopefully computers are fairly good at
doing sons unlike humans so that the
conception here is that the integral
equation is finding the area under the
curve exactly whereas the approximation
quadrature is you draw lots and lots of
rectangles underneath the curve and then
some the rectangles we can calculate
rectangles really quite nicely and so
yeah they're the pictures got three but
think of having a nice number like 10 to
the 7 so we're dealing with big numbers
here 10 to the 7
so what we want is code there's no again
the diagram there's no use so here's
some code nice sequential piece of code
that says yeah well yeah let's not worry
too much about the output that's just
printing stuff out i'm waffling for a
few seconds while people just read the
code that's sort of filler really run
anything else how many people would have
written that code yeah I think most of
us if we were being honest would have
written that code how many people though
would have returned that code possibly
not as many unless you come from a
haskell background in which case you
would say that this first form was
complete and a perma it defies the rules
of programming where you must never have
explicit iteration and the functional
programs wouldn't be too happy with this
because they know under the covers
reduces actually got iteration in it but
yeah it's declarative yeah it's not and
I'm not going to try running things from
from this wonderful editor because it
will all go wrong so I've got
pre-prepared some nice proper terminals
down here we were actually going to run
things from and so that particular piece
of code I put glasses on so you can
actually look at this stuff python3
probably sequential probably to do with
range multiply and we just run that code
and away goes whenever you're doing this
sort of micro benchmarking things UN you
end up wanting so about 2 to 10 seconds
worth of activity to get rid of any
smoothing and unlike what I'm going to
do here if you were doing proper
benchmarking you would take lots and
lots of samples and do the mean standard
deviation
all the analysis of variance i'm just
showing one data point indicative no
absolute facts coming out of this and
there it is 3.56 that's the range one
explicit iteration so let's do a bit of
implicit iteration with the reduced
version smaller bigger smaller Big O
whose for smaller whose for bigger how
about 5050 okay so we could make a book
on this excellent again be aware one
data point we can apparently implicit
iteration might possible good hypothesis
might be faster if you think about it
implicit iteration is always going to be
able to cheat it doesn't have to have a
perfectly formed Python peep at every
stage round the iteration whereas the
explicit iteration one is dealing with a
well-formed Python eat at every state so
the hint there that if we're looking for
some performance we want to not use the
ink if at all possible of course we
could do something really cool and say
the C Python interpreters a crock of
everyone
would help if I put a 3 on the end okay
so anybody using the C Python
interpreter for computation stop it now
yeah true true yeah well i will come to
numpy in a moment we could wonder course
do the other one got to be fair with
this only one data point not a fact that
a nice interesting hypothesis okay so
implicit iteration on pi PI big wing or
is it is it a big win enough don't know
and what else can we have a look at in
here and if it's not going fast enough
what do people normally do I suspect the
words siphon might will appear we know
where the connections yeah okay yeah
that's true okay so can we profile this
and find out where the bottleneck is yes
it's the for loop I've pretty straight
forward on that in general in you're
absolutely right in this particular case
it turns out something shouldn't alter
five across the same that is true yes
absolutely and I'm taking the full loop
as a whole here run the bits but in
pointing generals absolutely right get
the profiler out and away you go and
basically read his book
put glasses on I can't see screen and
what Norman what people would normally
do is they would go down to something
like no not that one that one they would
go down something like this and right
there pi that will cut and paste you
this is a situation where you're allowed
to do cut and paste you cut the Python
paste it into a siphon file then
marketer that's what I've done here and
in this particular case perfectly
reasonable we've got see types here
we've got all the bounds checking stuff
it's the annotations and everything but
it's fundamentally cut and paste of the
Python code and you do that whoops went
the wrong way no we don't want to do pai
pai three on this one we just want the
pie Python words python3 extension
Python sequential engage brain
I've precompiled all of the executables
and to stop people getting bored to be
honest it's just watching scones at work
really just doesn't interest most people
okay so 1.59 and can anyone remember
what we had before and it was sort of up
here is about three ish so we've only
got half as fast I've seems a bit
strange yeah now count the zeros we've
forget ten to the seven we're now doing
10 to the 9 iterations so we've got
under Times more work in roughly half
the time that's pretty good going I
think yeah but why bother with all of
this stuff here this is not Python this
is annotated Python you have to be damn
careful with it why not use a language
that does it properly most people would
then say well we've got a you've got to
go to see and yes reticence good idea
because C is a really rather dangerous
language particularly for doing this
sort of stuff and so you then say are
what we've got to do it in C++ but
remember that C++ has changed moderately
and so I list I wonder what happens if I
try and look at the C++ inner in here
I'm going to be dangerous I'm going to
have a look at Python all the boost this
yeah let's a look at a boost one oh nice
I look at c plus platform okay you can
do stuff like that and you can then
directly call that pi PI or or C Python
and beats god explicit iteration this is
really not a good idea or does it matter
it's c++ and actually this would be
considered see written in C++
ancient 1998 type stuff most people
these days would be using boost library
or C++ 14 or something like that and you
get code looking like this this is
actually constructing an extension
directly using boost so down here
there's everything you need to do to
link Python to C++ once you've created
your shared object or if you're using
windows dll is anyone trying to use
windows not many people as interesting
is usually about sixty to seventy
percent an audience are having to suffer
with windows or some other actually like
it which end of waffle and i am hoping
the fonts big enough I should have asked
ages ago yep now people are not going to
be interested in any of that sort of
stuff are this do you like it you sure
it's horrible so we could run it I will
in a moment but how about proper
languages language is like d
so you could do for each all the usual
rubbish now oh no no no let's get down
here reduce and then you get lambda
expression and yatta which is basically
a range and it in this particular
instance I've not beautified it nicely
and but a lot of people see this and
they think well why bother with Python
we just do the whole thing indeed if
you're doing computations stuff and lot
of people have one or two the hedge
funds in around London giving up using
Python just gone straight started using
d this pulls there for a minute and run
some runs and stuff so if we pie put
glasses on Python three sequential
extension boost okay so you leave it
faster than the siphon again be careful
one data point statistics etc etc
hypothesis is that we are getting faster
now I have to do something if I was just
to do the the D version it's going to
get very upset because I need to add
things to the Python path and add things
to the load library graph because things
are not in the standard place I'm having
to build things at the moment because
fedora doesn't have things in the
distribution so I'm hoping that if I
just do pythonpath the one I prepared
earlier because i watched Blue Peter get
prepared the way it goes 1.42 can you
tell the difference between booth c++
and d can't tell need the statistics
hypothesis about same speed are we doing
10 to the 9 yes are we beating siphon
yes are we beating Python
pi PI yes yes yes yes yes so if you're
wanting computation actual raw speed on
sequential you should be looking to
Python for the controller some other
language for the actual computation I
don't mean use number I would have tried
a number on here but I can't get it to
install and won't install at all but
that's only part of the story and if
you've been looking at the code down
there you'll have got a glimpse of some
of the other story which is sequential
versus parallel because we're living in
a world now where your phone's got more
calls than a Cray x1 so did i do c++ yes
did i do do yes have I done Chapel not
yet we'll come to that one but this
problem finding pie chosen because it's
embarrassingly parallel you can add
these numbers up any which way you like
because of the associativity and
commutativity of maths if we're gettin
down to real processes you have to study
for five years numerical analysis to
understand how to handle the errors and
correctly some these things up and then
you realize for this for this particular
demo it doesn't matter because at the
end of the day we've only got like five
or six significant digits anyway because
we're using 64-bit numbers but the
conception is we're just doing it
scatter gather data parallel so masses
of parallelism out there sadly this
thing only has to cause it says it's got
four that's lying of course because two
calls with hyper threads if you've ever
done any benchmarking you will realize
the hyper threads are a waste of time
and so let's have a look a bit of the
bits of code first and then I will hope
that my ssh connection to a real
workstation is still up what's the
parallelism think well that's nice do it
now actually ah still up excellent so if
we've got pie Python 3 and we want to do
parallel oh we haven't got players do
the threads because you're supposed to
use threads to get parallelism on you
and of course how everybody knows about
a guild only so we know that pythons I
can use the word sucks when it comes to
doing anything in parallel so let's not
just not even go there the pie pie with
the stn may well help not only for sheer
speed but also software transactional
memory beats deal every day of the week
I think so anyway let's not worry too
much about that because we're just
assuming can't do the thing unless you
do the site and thing so we can do we
can do parallel extension with siphon
now we will get a number of we won't hmm
2.82 right it's just a data point what
happens if we do the same thing with
boost and C++ okay cyclin losses
even on one data point i would say sighs
and losses but i forgot to do the
pythonpath thing that's a bit annoying
what's the problem there and that's the
sequential one I just did the wrong
current pace but what he does show is
that this machine I'm connected to is
very much slower sequentially and that
oh well that's not not unreasonable cuz
the laptops 2014 the workstation were
connected to hear 2006 but he's twinsies
on so it's got eight real calls on there
so compared to the sequential fully
parallel should be eight times faster
that looks about eight times faster to
name again so any single gate point
statistics blah blah blah blah blah you
impressed yet let's have a look at the
code just to make sure you're fairly
impressed so the decode the sequential
with the for loop sequential with reduce
parallel is just reduce because D comes
ready made with a thread pool you just
submit tasks to anyone who's done what's
the the Python 31 the executives they
are concurrent futures which is
basically stolen directly from Fort join
in Java because it's a good idea and the
implementation in fork joins not going
to work in other languages so well but
the whole idea of a tree-structured
parallelism works very well most task
pools will do
that whereas the Erlang style of just a
round-robin multiple schedulers and you
can make it work in other languages but
it is just much easier so we've just
thrown some number of tasks at this task
full it's organized them with the eight
machines underneath and come up with a
really nice piece of parallelism so that
the parallel code the sequential code
the sequential code the parallel code
and using this way of working we're
going to get really easy access to
parallelism I haven't got an example
here because I do not have the the kit
to do that available is when you want to
do GP GPUs then it really is going to be
you have to use into an implicit
iteration internal iteration or you're
just not going to get anywhere what
about the chapel
and well sadly I didn't manage to get
Python and chapel connected to each
other this morning the there was a new
release of the pie chapel stuff fairly
recently and I have been busy at
conferences for the last two weeks and
didn't get chance to actually just sit
down for an hour and get the thing
working but just to give an indication
of sort of style of programming that's
going on well that one's the chapel so
we have a quick look I will use the one
true editor here none of this vin lark
please so we want the sequential for
just too weird not apply because then
that's the comparison oops so that's the
sort of explicit iteration type thing is
it modern style of imperative
programming where you have as much type
inference as it's possible to get but if
you want to be explicit you can none of
this valve valve rubbish because that's
in terms of psychology programming
differencing viral is almost zero so
here you've got constant var and perrin
and how many Fortran program is have we
got in the room one or two so the proud
parents straight out of Fortran thinking
really and that works but as you've
probably spotted it's not really the way
you would go forward you'd actually have
produce which we got over here
now I've made this a bit trickier than
perhaps it should have been because I've
been experimentally batching so instead
of letting the thread pull work on
things explicitly map some slices of the
number of tasks down to the number of
processes that you've got and I've also
been parameter parameterizing this on
the number of tasks to compare scaling
so 1 2 832 to see if we're actually
getting some form of linear scaling here
i'll do i'll run those in a moment why
am i tall interested in languages like
chapel and that's because there are a
group of languages that go under the
heading of p gas which is partitioned
global address space so your program has
a single address space and within it you
partition it into domains and one domain
may map to a cluster item on the other
side of the world one might map to a
cluster item on the other side of the
room you are in control of working with
those domains so you're in control of
the clustering that's going on you might
have all of your processors on the one
machine in which case you've got very
light communication point there is
you've abstracted over local processors
clusters but in a way that you're in
control many of the actor frameworks
just say oh you put the actors anywhere
and ignore the communications cause the
idea of the partition global address
space is that you're very much in
control of the communications costs in
the global address space yourself and so
that's why I've got processors whoops
wrong wrong marker there this is
actually describing a data parallel
local
activity and that's what i want for
going on demos because i have to make
sure i can do things on the single
machine here so just running these PI
but I did the sequential one first night
it would help if I could spell pi
sequential I think with four multiplied
was the one I showed to make sense and
so we're not losing anything it's the
same ballpark of performance for
sequential so c++ d Chapel roughly the
same you can pair it with seeing roughly
the same not really much overhead if i
do the reduce one would help if i just
did by reduce okay so we're looking at
scaling with one task to task eight task
32 tasks and does it look like it's
going 1288 roughly again it's not
statistically significant to the single
data point we'd have to do lots lot but
it looks like we're getting roughly
linear scaling which is what
theoretically we should get out of this
and if i did this with d we get roughly
the same thing if i did this with c++ we
get roughly the same thing if i do this
with python we get 11 11 unless you use
siphon but we've seen that siphons going
to be a lot slower than these languages
are we winning here maybe maybe not I
did code and if anyone really does want
to look at this code it's all on github
you just go to my to me on github so
Russell github you'll find pi underscore
quadrature and yeah there's a few
languages in there I haven't done COBOL
yet but I don't think that's going to be
very interesting so we had a look a
little bit of C++ code start off with
pure python showed the pipe i just wings
compared to seep iceland full stop no
contest but c++ d are going to beat that
situation and will be cycling chapel a
new player in the game that's not ready
for production as yet the fade i can't
do a demo is sort of bit of an
indication that that's the case but I've
got great hopes for it because it deals
with all of the power ism because of the
PAS partition global address space model
you can program the core computation
with all its parallelism in your single
program I think that's a big win and
bigger win then you get rid D and
certainly with C++ although C++ has
threads it has no play in the cluster
game d has actors and threads in the in
the language but it doesn't have a play
in the cluster going Chapel has given
you a play in the multiple processors on
one machine and clusters through the P
gas model so i think that's
that's me four minutes over us it's a
three minutes over the half an hour of
apologies for that I tend to get excited
how do you think I hope that never mind
and you can read the slides and I didn't
do the numpy one because I thought that
might get too aggressive we need like 90
minutes to do with that one numpy forget
it it's just not up to it the it cannot
do the automated parallelism well enough
to get anywhere near competing with c++
d and chapel and i can run the numbers
if you want and they will always be
worse sadly number is interesting though
because it's trying to do Python to llvm
by codes and it actually does quite a
good job in many many cases it's just
not ready for primetime yet witness the
fact I can't do a demo because I can't
load it into a virtual environment so my
real pitch here is that python is great
for i/o bound python is great for
managing python is not great for doing
the computation itself so why bother
let's get to the multi-language
programmers polyglot i think is the
trendy term for it you know pick one c++
world know people groaned when i showed
c++ d chapel chapels my favorite at the
moment there will be new ones but let's
get polyglot rather than obsess about
using python across the board yeah well
let's just not go there for the moment
so that's me done for presentation are
there any questions out there we have
one there immediately
sorry that gives time for the apology
yes of course the clapping was there to
give time for the person to bring the
microphone right so I really like the
talk although it made me really angry um
so I did think it was a it's a really
bad I mean it's a example that really
shows the perhaps the an ideal pneus for
that particular problem of the Python
language choices right I think it's a
problem also that isn't as you as you
point out isn't easily optimized by
numpy so why are you doing it and I was
really angry I was writing an umpire
implementation that I think if I
profiled it which I didn't have time to
notice a Chromebook so it's not ideal
the main time there was spent in memory
allocation right because if you turn
that into a into a vectorized operation
you just end up allocating loads of
memory which takes a long time as well
right yeah but there's an awful lot of
stuff that you can do in parallel with
numpy so um I mean I've I've never had
to in Python do an algorithm like you've
implemented there quickly um either
they'll be a see library that does it
for me yeah or they'll be something I
can do in numpy so I kind of while I
appreciate that you're kind of pointing
this out as a problem I've never
actually come across it in the wild and
I just wonder if maybe we're being a
little bit disingenuous to suggest that
because numpy can't do these fast loops
over something where you're incrementing
variables it's therefore kind of slow
and the problem is that people are
beginning to rely on numpy and they
think so it's the blinkered vision that
worries me they say oh we can't do this
faster in Python we can do it in numpy
it's faster in numpy than invite them
therefore it'll do whereas in fact if
you go one stage further it'll go likely
10 times faster so i think i think my
cancer
that is that the pythons died one of the
reasons the Python exists is a glue
language for see like libraries right
yeah so I think if you if your tenant is
that basically we should be using it
more like that so and the other library
should be thought of as part of the
ecosystem then I suppose I'm kind of
pretty close to your thinking but I
still feel that there's an awful lot in
Python like numpy and stuff what you can
just rely on those things but yeah
you're right that we shouldn't be
blinkered by it it is if you for people
who are experimenting with algorithms
and stuff like that and they just don't
go fast enough in pure fight then they
go fast enough in number by who's
worrying about it a lot of the guys
doing the quant algorithms go that far
is it fast enough yes have we done the
job yes it's for production codes where
you actually really do need raw
performance and the python is there to
do the rendering of the imagery
matplotlib may not be fast enough but
that idea of offloading to python the
i/o staff the rendering stuff is the
model that CERN's got is fine I'm just
not convinced the C++ or C is the right
language for the extensions I'm thinking
we should do it with champion leave that
one there for a minute I saw a hand over
their first all night and then there's
number 2 over here number three down
here just one of the things that
surprised me is how quickly you wrote
off psyphon because one of the nice
things about it is you really can't just
cut and paste your code and it gets you
most of the way there well I think these
the same argument that we've just had
hear about numpy applies there if it's
too slow in Python then you go to site
then and it's fast enough and you've
done your job who's good who's arguing
it's when you then put it into
continuous production over and over
again and you could get ten times the
speed out of it by going a little bit
further than just siphon I think it was
person here who's already gotten like um
I was just going to ask if you look to
Julia and where does that fit in with
all the other julia is very interesting
it's not getting the traction yet
because there's people still trying to
get off matter matlab and those people
have heard about syfy and lumpy and
they've just moved from matplotlib to
their they haven't looked at julia yet
so i think we need a couple more years
before we find out where the juniors
going to make it i'm not played with it
is it's very nice do you know where it
sort of fits in your benchmark it and i
haven't done actual benchmarks for it
but it does fit in just above siphon so
it is faster than site and that's for
sure but it's not quite as fast as well
the very fastest is really hard coded
c++ c doesn't come anywhere near it your
real speed you have to go for threaded
building blocks with C++ and the code is
not pretty I think we probably get into
a stage we have to ask for the last
question another oh right so you I've
heard about that since D was started it
was C++ but sane and he kind of gave the
same impression why is d not more
popular and well d beside Walter bright
yes but 11 years old now and he was just
a pet project of his because he's a
compiler writer and he wanted to fix C++
absolutely right and he in a sense it
had no traction at all and then andrew
alexander s qu did his PhD thesis having
been a big c plus plus icon and decided
c++ was a crock of stuff and joined
Walter doing d and they the problem
perhaps i'm speculating a bit here is
that there was d1 and in d2 and it was a
bit of political warfare between group
and that really ruins anybody in
industry taking the language seriously
and it's only just recovering there are
still bits of internecine warfare
between various folks but d2 is now
production ready it's used in production
in facebook as well as other
organizations and raised got budget to
get bugs fixed and stuff like that he
himself works part time so Facebook now
believe that D can be an integral part
of their software development for a
framework that has changed people's
views also the moment the bulk of people
who are actually using a fairly game
oriented not triple-a but the Wonder
live and so there's a lot of d used in
games production you just don't hear
about that and so a lot of there is a
bit of good solid traction for d but can
it be rust now that rust has got all
this sales pitch going on from Mozilla
interesting times so traction no not yet
could it have yes I think it could and
now is the time for a bit